command the Seas with history's most
iconic war vessels in the latest free to
play combat game world of warships
download now hey guys today is the first
of October my name is Jess and here's
what happened in gaming today back in
September Star Fox zero was delayed to
allow for additional Polish reportedly
the game is now running really smoothly
at 60 frames per second on both the Wii
U gamepad and TV screen Star Fox zero
co-director yosuke Hashimoto told
GameSpot we've got them both moving at
60 frames per second which is big for a
lot of people I think it's kind of a
milestone in gaming in a way it's not
something that we've done ourselves
before at platinum and it's just not
even something that's been done in
gaming before Hashimoto added that a
large challenge for the studio has been
ensuring both screens feel natural and
interesting explaining the wild platinum
know their way around action games
creating a shooter using the gamepad is
a brand-new learning experience Star Fox
zero is due out next year Square Enix
have opted to scrap their Deus Ex
mankind divided augmented pre-orders
program after eight hell of a lot of
backlash the original plan was to offer
multiple tiers of rewards depending on
how many pre-orders went through and
what is only the second dumbest
marketing decision we've talked about
this week the publisher had initially
wanted to give away DLC if enough global
pre-orders were hit third DLC included
in Game costumes soundtracks and extra
missions then if even more of you
pre-ordered the game the plan was to
have the game release four days ahead of
schedule Square explained when it was
first conceived we wanted the program to
give you more choice about what you
received in terms of pre-order
incentives in the past when we chose
those packages ourselves and split them
across regions it caused frustration we
quickly noticed that this new approach
created even more frustration resulting
in a resounding
of negative feedback now everybody who
pre-orders or purchases a day one
edition will get all of the incentive
content and everybody will get the game
on februari 23 of next year as
originally planned another DLC and
pre-ordering news be fallout 4 DLC
season pass is now available for
pre-order on the Xbox one the season
pass which Bethesda hasn't even
announced content for yet is now living
on the xbox marketplace and you can drop
30 bucks on it right now it's just so
choose but there's the marketing exec
Pete Hines has told fans to stay tuned
pre-order details to ps4 and PC you're
also now able to pre-order the $90 flat
for digital deluxe bundle which includes
the game and the season pass fallout 4
is due out on November 10 and is the VLC
will start to be released next year let
me know down in that comment box if you
plan to preorder fallout floors DLC or
not and why you can add a game spot
we've got stories on the success of soma
and the gears of war Xbox one bundle
that is everything I have for you today
but be sure to join me same time
tomorrow where I'll have my top five
stories of the whole gaming week I hope
to catch the vent